ah
[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález la pobreza
extrema afecta a venezuela así lo
evidencia el resultado de un estudio
realizado por la universidad católica
andrés bello una institución privada que
se basó en la encuesta nacional de
condiciones de vida eco vi una encuesta
que fue creada en el año 2014 para
obtener información y así compensar la
ausencia de datos oficiales en venezuela
veamos algunos de estos datos veamos
algunas de las cifras destacadas por
ejemplo la pobreza alcanza a tres de
cada cuatro venezolanos la pobreza llega
ya al 90 y 4.5 por ciento la pobreza
extrema es decir quienes viven con un
poco más de un dólar al día ya alcanza
el 76.6 por ciento según esta encuesta
el 65.2 por ciento de los hogares
venezolanos se privan de algún aspecto
básico como por ejemplo comprar
alimentos el producto interno bruto de
venezuela se contrajo un 74% entre el
2014 y el 2020 son tan sólo algunas de
las cifras como para que ustedes hagan
una idea son múltiples también las las
razones las causas que han llevado a que
venezuela esté en este escenario tan
difícil para los ciudadanos la mala
gestión económica la hiperinflación que
también ha llevado a que en diferentes
ocasiones hayan tenido que devaluar la
moneda en múltiples oportunidades
de hecho el cono monetario vigente es el
bolívar digital que recientemente entró
en circulación también la crisis de los
combustibles ha generado dificultades a
los venezolanos pese a tener una de las
mayores reservas de petróleo del mundo
venezuela no tiene combustible
la difícil situación económica política
y también sanitaria de venezuela ha
llevado a que más de 5 millones de
ciudadanos venezolanos hayan tenido que
irse de su país a lo largo de los
últimos años en un inicio muchos de
ellos se fueron a europa otros a eeuu y
ahora unas olas migratorias recientes
las hemos visto en las imágenes a los
migrantes a pie hasta para algunos
países vecinos la gran pregunta es que
dice el gobierno de nicolás maduro pues
que tal vez todo es culpa de eeuu de las
sanciones internacionales pero también
hay una mala gestión el mal manejo de
los recursos y el desperdicio de las
bondades que trajo en su momento tener
el galón de petróleo por encima de los
100 dólares para invertir en la
infraestructura de los servicios básicos
que tanto están afectando también las
sanciones internacionales y la presión
que ejerce la comunidad internacional
sobre el gobierno de nicolás maduro que
dicen directamente los afectados los
venezolanos cómo buscar mejorar la
situación de ellos qué puede hacer la
comunidad internacional hay múltiples
preguntas que tenemos para este debate
de france 24 que se enfoca en la crítica
situación de venezuela para profundizar
en este tema saludamos a karim vera
diputada de la asamblea nacional de
venezuela entre los años 2015 y 2020
también es coordinadora de primero
justicia del estado de táchira ella se
encuentra en san juan de colonia en el
estado de táchira también está con
nosotros william benavides diputado de
la asamblea nacional de venezuela por el
movimiento tupamaro él se encuentra en
la capital en la ciudad de caracas y
aquí en el estudio de france 24 está con
nosotros ronald rodríguez investigador
del observatorio de venezuela de la
universidad del rosario que está ubicada
en la ciudad de bogotá la capital
colombiana ustedes también son parte de
este debate pueden dejar sus comentarios
y todas sus preguntas a través de
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter nos
pueden encontrar como france24
bajo ese i arroba sant y luego les
recuerdo que nuestra etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 pues comenzamos
entonces con karim en en el estado
táchira preguntándole y tal vez la
pregunta más importante de todo el
debate qué hacer con la pobreza social
en venezuela cariño
buenas noches santiago sin duda
venezuela está presentando unas cifras
alarmantes en cuanto a la situación de
pobreza en la familia venezolana cuatro
de cada cuatro familias presentan una
situación abrumadora una
profunda tragedia que obliga a que esa
familia se reinvente porque con el
salario mínimo promedio del venezolano
no le alcanza ni siquiera para comprar
un kilo de harina pan que le permita
cubrir una necesidad inmediata y en ese
reinventarse una de las opciones la
alternativa es huir de venezuela incluso
caminando por todo el país con destino
hacia parte a otras naciones en busca de
mejores condiciones de vida que le
permita satisfacer sus necesidades muy
personales y poder ayudar a estos
familiares que quedan en el país en el
país y poderlos ayudar a sobrellevar la
profunda crisis que se ha causado por
las malas políticas
a lo largo de los últimos años william
en la ciudad de caracas que piensa usted
cómo hacer frente a esta pobreza esta
crisis social que está presentando
venezuela
buenas noches gracias por la invitación
nuevamente primero que no estoy de
acuerdo todos los indicadores que existe
por lo que hay una encuesta de una
universidad en particular lo otro hablar
sobre algunos porcentajes y sobre mala
gestión económica sería desconocer que
en venezuela hay un bloqueo económico
una persecución económica de varios años
nosotros lo hemos denunciado
históricamente
sería también desconocer por ejemplo el
caso el decreto 008 del banco central
colombiano también como agrede desde las
casas de cambio de la frontera con
colombia todo un proceso de persecución
que no permite que nosotros compremos
repuestos la persecución a nuestras
cuentas internacionales como nos
quitaron 5 como no quitan monómeros como
nos quitan el oro en inglaterra como es
la persecución a todas nuestras cuentas
internacionales por supuesto que ahorita
nosotros damos un proceso de producción
hoy en una asamblea nacional
de promulgar la ley de emprendimiento en
su última discusión un proceso de
discusión que nuestro pueblo está
buscando alternativa
preguntando la solución y la salida a
esta crisis no las causas eso ya lo
hemos visto y lo hemos visto porque el
turismo está desde el 99 le está
preguntando por ese tipo de medidas una
ley de emprendimiento para fomentar la
creación de empresas venezuela william
justamente tiene que ver con eso
nosotros no hemos desperdiciado como te
acaban de decir ahí la bonanza apertura
nosotros construimos infraestructura
hemos construido infraestructuras de
todo tipo y está ahorita en un proceso
de recuperación de todo ese proceso de
infraestuctura por supuesto que la
guerra económica ha golpeado y tiene que
golpear un proceso de sanciones ahora el
emprendimiento mira la producción cuando
hablamos del tema de la alimentación
recientemente en una comisión de la faa
venezuela enviada por la onu y pudo
revisar como todo el proceso de
producción de semillas de agroinsumos de
producción nuestra de soberanía
alimentaria mil 70 por ciento de los
productos que ahorita se están
distribuyendo en la cac la son productos
nacionales cuando antes no era así que
quiere decir que hay una mejoría que hay
un proceso de recuperación económica por
supuesto que nosotros queremos que nos
permitan vender nuestro petróleo
nuestras materias primas que producimos
el aluminio que nos permitan producir el
hierro igual nosotros un proceso de
emprendimiento nacional sería también
desconocer lo estamos haciendo
ingeniería inversa
en eso el mantenimiento de nuestro pleno
nuestro ferrocarril el mantenimiento del
barco
le pido que sea puntual porque tengo que
darle la palabra también a los otros
invitados para que haya equilibrio aquí
en la participación y tengo otro
invitado acá en el estudio que tiene
también cosas para decir
aquí en el estudio ronald rodríguez nos
acompaña
ronald como entender esta crisis de la
pobreza que estaba viviendo venezuela y
que puede empezar a hacer este país para
para salir adelante con estas sanciones
internacionales que tiene impuestas por
eeuu y las dificultades que tiene
internamente el país como cualquier país
que está haciendo crisis por la pandemia
coi 19 y tiene problemas sociales como
cualquier nación suramericana de hecho
santiago la particularidad viene de
venezuela en el marco de la crisis que
ha generado la cob y es que se
estabilizó en la precariedad mientras
otros países retrocedieron
económicamente de forma importante por
las dinámicas de la pandemia en el caso
de venezuela donde la economía ya estaba
en un piso profundo la pandemia no
terminó golpeando los tanto la dinámica
de la falta de combustible pues limita
movilidad de los ciudadanos hoy viajar
desde caracas a la zona de frontera se
consiguiente que es por 800 dólares
precio que no puede pagar un venezolano
de a pie y obviamente pues esto digamos
evitado que la pandemia golpe tan fuerte
a venezuela y en los últimos meses hay
que reconocerlo que ha mejorado el
abastecimiento pero no porque las
políticas del gobierno hayan permitido
la mejora de ese abastecimiento sino
porque han surgido una serie de mercados
paralelos que evaden las sanciones que
traen productos o llevan productos a
venezuela a través de dinámicas de
correo y la diáspora venezolana estamos
hablando de que venezuela en los últimos
seis años perdió el 17 por ciento de su
población le permite la llegada de una
serie de recursos que hace que la vida
de los venezolanos no sea óptima pero
que ya no está enfrentando esa dinámica
de desabastecimiento hoy se encuentran
productos en los anaqueles el problema
es que la gran mayoría de los
venezolanos no tienen acceso a ellos
dependen de lo que hacen sus
compatriotas en el exterior y lo que uno
esperaría es que se empiecen a tomar
medidas para recuperar la economía
obviamente cuando hablamos de confianza
cuando hablamos de que todos los países
de américa latina están buscando
recursos para recuperar sus economías
uno de los países que menos confianza
genera es venezuela sus políticas
macroeconómicas a lo largo de los 20
años de revolución bolivariana le han
quitado la posibilidad de acceder a los
recursos de la banca multilateral le han
quitado la posibilidad de que los
inversionistas lleven sus recursos a
venezuela y los que quieren invertir
pues son actores no continentales
actores que tienen unas dinámicas que
están dispuestas a digamos a explotar a
venezuela de forma
violando toda su dinámica ecológica de
hecho pues hay unas preocupaciones en el
continente por cómo hacer las
explotaciones que vienen por fuera del
continente en las cuales no se están
teniendo los cuidados medioambientales y
que van a afectar no solamente la
amazonía venezolana sino la amazonía en
general entonces estamos en un punto
difícil todos los países estamos
buscando recursos y lamentablemente
venezuela son los países que menos
acceso tiene los recursos en este
momento que en el estado táchira podemos
de acuerdo a lo que hemos hablado y de
acuerdo a lo que ustedes evidencian allí
en el día a día de los venezolanos se
puede hablar de una emergencia
alimentaria en este país en este momento
el estado tracción es uno de los estados
que estaban más cercados y más asediado
por las malas políticas económicas
implementadas por el régimen de nicolás
maduro y se ha visto en la necesidad
imperiosa de sobrevivir a cuenta del
contrabando un contrabando de mercancías
que vienen desde colombia para poder
abastecer el mercado local en todo el
estado táchira y que a su vez propiciado
por un nuevo protectorado que este
impuesto en todo el estado táchira
encabezado por freddy bernal que quien
tiene el gran monopolio de este
contrabando porque desde allí se otorgan
algunos códigos o algunos permisos que
per
que a través de los pasos irregulares no
los conoce sólo popularmente conocidos
como trochas accedan a territorio
venezolano
las corten a lo largo de todo el país
mercancías que vienen desde colombia que
no pasan o no cumplen con los
requerimientos
fundamentales para la nacionalización de
la mercancía pero que de alguna manera
se convierte en un mercado alterno para
procurar la alimentación plena de elsur
es porque le resulta mucho más económico
alta accidente abastecerse de esos
productos colombianos
acceder al producto
prom hecho en venezuela mejor que por lo
graves lina son mucho más costosos
traerlos a nuestro estado sin ti no sólo
por las que acepte hoy presenta el trade
sino que el estado planea 2002 tiene una
profunda crisis de la gasolina cuando no
había canciones como lo plantea digo
sino que sencillamente en venezuela
tenemos grandes problemas de producción
producto de la ruina en la cual se
unieron a petróleos de venezuela quienes
hoy encabezan el régimen de licor amado
si quiero ir la otra versión de los
hechos la versión más de la de la cara
del estado william que ha hecho entonces
el gobierno de nicolás maduro para hacer
frente a estas dificultades como han
sorteado ustedes estas
barricadas que se le presentan en el
camino a venezuela para poder avanzar
económicamente
cuáles han sido los avances por favor
sea muy puntual porque ustedes ms me
empieza a alargar y el tiempo es muy
corto
y yo te hablo como diputado nacional de
un partido no uno como gobierno como tal
claro cero del gobierno claro mira
nosotros que hemos hecho que hemos
estado realizando la innovación es
importante el emprendimiento nos estamos
produciendo piezas para tractores
estamos produciendo piezas para todo
tipo de maquinaria o sea el el
planteamiento de la guerra económica el
cerco que tienen contravencional no ha
permitido a nosotros desarrollar innovar
producir en venezuela y nosotros
seguimos confiando y seguimos confiando
en la mejoría económica errores que se
han cometido en tema económico de
producción por supuesto que los hay por
supuesto que están pero a nosotros este
cerco económico este cerco financiero no
ha permitido a nosotros creer
fundamentalmente en los poderes de
desarrollo que tiene algo interno el
pueblo venezolano y mira por ejemplo
cuando yo escucho este compañero
analista que dice un tiquete 800 dólares
de cualquier parte de venezuela hacia la
frontera es una mentira eso no cuesta ni
siquiera un tiquete desde avión vale por
favor o sea no sigamos mintiéndole al
mundo sobre el caso venezolano
francia 24 a una delegación que venga a
venezuela y vea todo el proceso de
emprendimiento y desarrollo económico
una economía alternativa por supuesto en
microeconomía emparejándose con la con
la macroeconomía eso lo que queremos
pero también queremos que no quiten todo
el proceso de sanciones de persecución
económica de persecución william a las
empresas que están produciendo en
venezuela
y cuáles son y cuáles son esas áreas en
las que se está haciendo énfasis para
para desarrollar esas microempresas que
a las que le están apostando a que le
está apostando la economía venezolana
mira la agricultura la producción la
agricultura la soberanía alimentaria se
está apostando muchísimo a ese tema
también a la minería hay un gran
desarrollo de la pequeña minería y la
gran minería el desarrollo nuestro por
ejemplo emprendimiento que tiene cuerpo
la industria petrolera pequeñas empresas
produciendo el cambio de piezas
internacionales la pieza nacional para
nadie es un secreto que todas las
refinerías nuestra tecnología
norteamericana nos permiten y se
encuentran y siguen tornillo en tu sitio
buscar innovar y quería empezar a
producir herramientas mira en venezuela
no se ve producido un avión en venecia
no producimos un avión encima 100 y el
símbolo del psib o 200 no se han
producido barco estamos produciendo
barco estamos ahorita en el desarrollo
del tren caracas y no nos permitían a
nosotras el repuesto de tecnología
entonces quiere decir que hay un proceso
de empoderamiento de la clase
trabajadora de la clase obrera con esa
ingeniería inversa que se está
apropiando el desarrollo y eso queremos
que él va a apalancar mucho la economía
venezolana los próximos 15 20 años de
desarrollo
aquí la perspectiva nos dice los
indicadores nos da otro tipo de
referencias y tal vez la perspectiva que
tenemos desde afuera es completamente
diferente pero qué repercusión es ronald
puede tener a mediano y a largo plazo
tener a una población en la pobreza mal
alimentada con mala infraestructura es
evidente lo hemos visto en reportajes
recientes las condiciones en las que se
encuentran las escuelas venezolanas
ahora que están próximos a comenzar el
año a comenzar otra vez las clases
presenciales después de la ausencia de
los alumnos por la por el kobe 19 esto
qué repercusiones trae para un país y
para una sociedad pues empezando la
encuesta en kobe precisamente los datos
que ustedes han presentado es un
ejercicio ante la falta de información
la universidad andrés bello la
universidad central la universidad simón
bolívar hicieron un ejercicio de empezar
a levantar datos porque para poder
diseñar políticas de respuesta lo
primero hay que tener es un diagnóstico
más o menos de lo que está sucediendo
lamentablemente el estado venezolano que
dirige nicolás y dejó de entregar
información en materia social casi que
desde el 2006 de ahí para acá la
información fue fragmentada y en los
últimos años se dejó de entregar
información hoy el diagnóstico que nos
hace la encuesta en kobe es un
diagnóstico bastante duro por un lado
nos dice que la esperanza de los
venezolanos ha retrocedido esto en
materia demográfica es terrible es el
único país del continente que está
retrocediendo en esperanza de vida el
dato de pobreza el dato de la migración
son datos que limitan la capacidad de
recuperación de venezuela en el largo
plazo están perdiendo todo su bono
demográfico hoy el bono demográfico de
venezuela se encuentra desperdigado por
los países de la región se encuentra en
condición de movilidad humana y
obviamente pues plantear cómo puede
salir venezuela de esto lo primero es
que es necesaria una salida política y
eso es absolutamente claro otras salidas
otras alternativas que en algún momento
se pensaron que todas las alternativas
están sobre la mesa se busca una salida
digamos por la fuerza de venezuela eso
no va a resultar en el caso venezolano y
la recuperación no hacer una
recuperación inmediata las posturas que
decían no lo que se necesita en
venezuela es unas elecciones
presidenciales
transparentes con un acompañamiento
internacional el problema venezuela es
tan estructural que una elección no
resuelve el problema estamos hablando de
la pérdida del monopolio de la fuerza de
la pérdida del control territorial de la
destrucción del sistema económico del
colapso del sistema de salud y de
servicios sociales esto requiere una
respuesta regional y obviamente pues la
negociación es la salida a esta
situación una negociación que permita la
coexistencia con algunas facciones del
chavismo en el futuro es decir no es
simplemente sacar al chavismo y borrarlo
porque el chavismo estaría representando
un sector de la población que es
importante pero también buscar una
construcción de consenso de recuperación
de venezuela y eso se logra a través de
la negociación una negociación que no
será fácil que no sabemos si la de
méxico logre llevarnos hacia allá pero
la única posibilidad que tiene venezuela
es que él logre un consenso para
recuperar el estado venezuela
prácticamente retrocedió un siglo en
materia económica venezuela pobre a
principios del siglo 21
a principios del siglo 20 y
lamentablemente a principios del siglo
21 vuelve a ser un país pobre es como si
toda esa riqueza petrolera toda esa
inversión social todo ese capital humano
que se formó se perdiera por una una
dinámica administrativa y deponga cidad
política obviamente el futuro de
venezuela es complejo y tiene una
infección directa sobre colombia
colombia es el país más afectado por la
situación que ocurre en el hermano país
karim en el estado táchira le hago la
misma pregunta qué repercusiones puede
traer esto para los venezolanos al
mediano plazo ya lo vemos reflejado en
una migración una alta migración una
salida de casi 6 millones de venezolanos
de su país y bueno las dificultades que
ustedes ven en el día a día pero a
mediano plazo
fíjate que experto en materia
nutricional establece que venezuela ha
perdido una generación
en cuanto a los índices nutricionales
por la por la mala alimentación que hoy
tiene el venezolano promedió que sólo
alcanza los 4 dólares mensuales para
cubrir sus necesidades básicas al
mediano plazo tenemos un país
profundamente en retroceso como ya se
planteaba un país totalmente arruinado
con una población juvenil totalmente
desesperanzada que no ve el futuro en
nuestro país que toma la decisión de
huir como ya te decía incluso caminando
y tan cierto es el valor de un ticket
desde caracas hacia la frontera que
pueda alcanzar hasta los 500 dólares que
es lo que nosotros hemos podido
comprobarse y ante la imposibilidad del
ciudadano de poder pagar ese monto
críticamente transita las carreteras
nacionales de venezuela
a pie para poder unir al país en el día
de hoy
se estima que tenemos un aproximado de 6
millones de venezolanos que están
regados por el mundo y se estima que
este número siga incrementando porque
hoy las condiciones de vida hoy las
garantías de sobrevivencia que se
brindan en venezuela cada día están
mucho más disminuidas con un sistema
educativo
colapsado vimos cómo hacer 23 días atrás
el techo de una de las instituciones
educativas en el municipio seboruco aquí
en nuestro estado táchira con la chava
luego de año y medio de estar en plena
receso por la pandemia las instituciones
educativas totalmente por el suelo y aún
de manera cínica pretenden convocar a
nuestros niños a
retomar las clases clases presenciales
cuando tampoco han sido tenemos una
población que escasamente alcanza al 11
por ciento de haber recibido las vacunas
y todavía y pediste que esos productos
de las canciones cuando en venezuela
pero en el estado táchira del año 2009
tenemos una profunda crisis eléctrica y
que fueron en el año en este mismo año
2009 cuando se aporten recursos
milmillonarios para cubrir esta crisis
eléctrica y sencillamente el dinero fue
robado
doce años después estás demoras
william en la ciudad de caracas una de
las de los aspectos que llamaba la
atención en el inicio del gobierno de
hugo chávez era la gran cantidad de
programas sociales que comenzaron a
surgir desde el gobierno para ayudar a
las clases menos favorecidas allí en
venezuela en este momento que programas
sociales se mantienen que en este
momento le vendría muy bien a los
venezolanos seguir recibiendo estas
ayudas se mantienen estos servicios se
mantienen estas ayudas o esto también
desapareció porque el gobierno pues ya
tampoco tiene plata o no tiene como
traerlas los los fondos que tiene en
bancos internacionales
no se mantiene se mantiene igual marín
se han fortalecido sobre algunos temas
que surgen en puntuales mira 11 por
ciento de la vacunación eso es mentira
aquí hay estados como el estado miranda
que próximamente están por cumplir el
cien por ciento de la vacunación de la
de toda la población
otros temas que hemos escuchado
permanentemente el tema sobre la crisis
política interna sobre las posiciones
algunos hablaban de una salida militar
hace mucho tiempo otros siempre hemos
planteado la salida política y
entenderlo entre los venezolanos y que
respetemos primero la constitución y que
la comunidad internacional respete las
conversaciones las discusiones y las
negociaciones entre venezolanos nosotros
esperamos que ese sector que pedía
intervención militar que esté en méxico
ahorita sentar una conversación termine
de definir algunas cosas el sector está
participando ahorita en el proceso
interno electoral en venezuela es ese y
otro sector de la oposición que
fundamental es muy importante para la
estabilidad política en la estabilidad
de william pero
ramas sociales que programas se
mantienen y han servido para sortear
este momento de la crisis y le amplió la
pregunta a los t detención por ciento la
vacunación en el estado zulia esas
cifras de donde salen si no hay cifras
oficiales
miranda el estado mira miranda perdonado
miranda en venezuela en venezuela no
mira que aquí están son cifras que se
reportan diariamente de la comisión
presidencial del cobi y hay un reporte
es público notorio y comunicacional mira
nosotros aunque nos quieran colocar un
cerco mediático comunicacional
permanentemente esas son cifras que se
colocan aquí en venezuela y que son
abiertas en una rueda de prensa semanal
se colocan se publica la puede conseguir
cualquiera y están que nadie está
ocultando ningún datos sobre programas
sociales mira el carné de la patria el
proceso de vacunación el proceso de
atención al adulto mayor
lo que nosotros hemos denominado las
víctimas de la guerra porque hay una
guerra económica y si hay unas víctimas
por supuesto que hay unas víctimas
hermanos y si efectivamente son los
sectores más desposeídos los más pobres
que por supuesto el gobierno jamás lo ha
dejado de atender y la revolución
bolivariana jamás lo ha dejado de
atender y nosotros como organizaciones
revolucionarias jamás hemos dejado de
atender
ahorita efectivamente hay un programa la
gotita de amor a las escuelas y es
trabajo voluntario es trabajo del
ministerio educación que es el gobierno
es trabajo de todas las organizaciones
revolucionarias ya quiere decir que aquí
tenemos que trabajar hermanos con lo que
tenemos o sea desconocer que hay william
gay que allí por supuesto que escasez de
recursos porque bueno no tenemos que
decir que hubo un periodo donde nosotros
nos vendimos un barril de petróleo casi
un año sin vender un barril de petróleo
como se mantiene un país y esperaban que
aquí vinieron una super crisis la súper
inflación y que eso desencadenará una
guerra civil no se cree o no se va a dar
porque aquí no ven eso no estamos muy
claros del proyecto países tenemos
vuelve así nos tengan bloqueadas y no
tengan sancionados bueno
y luego porque el desa tocado cambiar de
cono monetario varias veces en los
últimos años precisamente para hacer
frente a la inversión
eso es una realidad
me quedan ya pocos minutos para terminar
el programa y quiero preguntar por acá
bien por la comunidad internacional qué
puede hacer la comunidad internacional
para ayudar en esta situación o que ha
dejado de hacer la comunidad
internacional para apoyar a venezuela
como lo vio usted
la comunidad internacional desde el año
2007 volvió su mirada muy
específicamente a la profunda crisis que
vivían los bienes que vivimos los
venezolanos y que nosotros venimos
denunciando a lo largo del régimen de
euros posteriormente nicolás maduro hoy
con fortuna la comunidad internacional
no sólo nos mira sino que nos apoya hoy
está en el proceso de negociación de
méxico apoyando alto venezolano a salir
de la profunda crisis a lograr
entendimiento a evitar de que el régimen
encabezado por nicolás maduro utilice el
proceso de negociación única y
exclusivamente para ganar tiempo y
sencillamente burlarte de las
necesidades del pueblo venezolano a mí
se me causa que me consta mucha risa
pero en un sentimiento encontrado
complot al oír de que existen programas
sociales que atienden por ejemplo al
adulto mayor cuando el adulto mayor
obtiene una pensión de escasa 20
de bolívar es cuando tenemos el precio
del dólar oficial del banco central de
venezuela
el régimen de nicolás maduro libertad de
los 5 bolívares por dólar es decir un
adulto mayor hoy sencillamente se muere
de hambre porque escasamente tiene una
pensión de 1.3 dólares no podemos ser
cínicos no podemos burlarnos de la
necesidad de los venezolanos y tenemos
que apostar seriamente a estos proyectos
de negociaciones con que tienen como
garantes a los amigos de venezuela que
están en la comunidad internacional para
lograr consolidar el cambio de modelo
político pro yo premia lo venezolano
porque misma nicolás maduro esté en el
palacio de miraflores la crisis y la
tragedia del pueblo venezolano
quiero hacer una precisión estábamos
poniendo de ejemplo la vacunación en el
estado miranda según la secretaria de
salud de ese estado mirelis guillén la
vacunación ronda el 70 por ciento no el
100 por ciento según la cuenta oficial
del gobierno del estado miranda la
vacunación va por el 60 por ciento
de acuerdo a las cifras publicadas el
día de hoy no el 100 por ciento
ronald para ir finalizando la comunidad
internacional qué papel tiene que jugar
acá colombia juega un papel fundamental
y hablaría del caso de colombia se debe
reabrir la frontera entre colombia y
venezuela debe recuperarse el paso de
mercancías de colombia hacia venezuela
independientemente de las posiciones
políticas que viva el hermano país la
realidad es que la frontera cerrada pone
en riesgo a los ciudadanos colombianos y
venezolanos que todos los días la
atraviesan los pone al margen de los
grupos de la ley que aprovechan esta
situación y tenemos una frontera que fue
cerrada hace 6 años cuando se expulsó de
forma arbitraria a más de 32 mil
compatriotas fueron echados y acusados
de ser los causantes de la crisis
económica en ese momento y de la
inseguridad pero más allá de pasar
cuentas de cobro de pasar facturas hay
que ir recuperando el tejido social de
la frontera la población tanto de
táchira como de norte de santander
tienen la necesidad de recuperar ese
vínculo de recuperar ese mercado de
poder dar dinámicas de abastecimiento y
obviamente pues vemos que en venezuela
no se vive en democracia pero colombia
también tiene relaciones con países que
no son democráticos y hay que recuperar
las relaciones consulares es fundamental
que tengamos representación consular del
régimen venezolano en territorio
colombiano pero también de los
colombianos en territorio venezolano es
un momento bastante difícil en la zona
de frontera cuando en este momento
parece que se empieza a trabajar esa
apertura
ronald me quedan pocos minutos ya para
hacer la conclusión y le y quiero que la
conclusión es la propongo en tipo
pregunta que tanto más puede sostenerse
este país y este régimen allí en el caso
venezolano nos dimos cuenta de que
siempre se puede empeorar es decir en
venezuela el deterioro económico social
se creía que no se podía llegar a que
más del 17 por ciento la población haya
tenido que salir del país buscando una
alternativa de vida eso ha aliviado la
situación social en venezuela pero
significa la pérdida del bono de un
gráfico karim la conclusión que viene
entonces para venezuela con esta crisis
rápidamente me queda solo minuto
bueno viene mucha mucha hambre mucha
miseria mucha migración que afecta a los
países hermanos que hoy reciben a los
venezolanos y es imperativo que las
partes involucradas en la solución del
conflicto lleguen a acuerdos importantes
pero sobre todo quienes ejercen o no de
manera arbitraria e inhumana el poder
asuman su responsabilidad para poder
avanzar y entiendan que mientras sigan
desconectados y en el pienso en la toma
arbitraria ícono del poder por el poder
en venezuela si querían aumentando los
límites pobremente william para el
cierre de 30 segundos su conclusión que
sigue para venezuela
bueno mucho trabajo de verdad que mucho
trabajo es demasiado y nosotros más
seguir trabajando cuando yo escucho a
veces decir eso que tienen amigos para
sacar un gobierno legítimamente
constituido y otro habla de que no hay
democracia entonces qué debate se puede
para siempre la vacunación y para acá es
decir que va por el setenta y tantos por
ciento quiere decir quien sea y datos si
hay información es oficial no le negamos
la información no hemos negado que
estamos bloqueados para nosotros lo que
en el gran trabajo para todas las
organizaciones revolucionar seguir
desarrollando nuestro país no va haber
más crisis para nosotros como ustedes la
plantea no va a venir una guerra no va a
venir ningún elemento súper
inflacionario para seguir trabajando y
cree en la venezuela productiva william
pues muchas muchas gracias por compartir
su punto de vista con nosotros a karim y
a ronald aquí en el estudio muchas
gracias también en nombre del equipo del
aura garzón en la producción y tania
herrera en la producción de invitados ya
todo el equipo de france 24 les
agradecemos su sintonía siga con
nosotros
[Música]